We're going to talk about going from
Galois fields to Reed-Solomon codes.
We must be mad, Sean. Really, I mean, so many
of you have said: "Just do Reed-Solomon,
y' know. You've done Hamming codes. They [Reed-Solomon]
can't be that much more complex?"  Oh yes they can!
The stuff we have done earlier - and we've done a
fair bit on Hamming codes, which if you
remember are basically going to correct a
... put right a single error. That all
happened in the 1960s. And in two of the
videos out there, which we'll put the
links out for you, I did a thing called
Multi-Dimensional Error Correction where
I had two bits of information (which was
a San Francisco state of weather). So
there was two bits for the state of the
weather, like I think it was '11' for "sunny",
or something like that. But in
order to protect those bits against a
1-bit damage, I had to add no fewer
than 3 extra bits. I had to make it into
a 5-bit code. But it was OK, because
checking up whether it had been damaged
was easy. It was a simple parity check. It
was effectively saying : "Look, here's the
3 parity-check bits at the end". I've
made the rule that overall it must be
even parity. I know that one of them says
'1' Another one says '0' but this [third] bit I
don't know. But it's got to be even
parity overall so if I've only got a single
'1'and a '0',  I need another '1' to
make that grouping be even parity.
Now that's the easy error correction. How did
it advance from that?  What changed?
Well, we're talking about 10 years hence. I
mean Richard Hamming was very definitely
late '50s / early '60s. The next
phase of this or, this "big jump forward"
thst we would want to do, was by Reed and Solomon [and]
was 10 years later. It was late '60s / early '70s.
O!h and big surprise:  Were Reed and
Solomon at Bell Labs ?! No! For a change.
Everybody else seemed to be at Bell Labs
[but] Reed and Solomon were,
I think, at  MIT's Lincoln Laboratory. But there
was a realization that if you wanted
more powerful error correction there
were several things you could do but, the
more they looked into it, the more they
found themselves having to learn about
Pure Mathematics concepts called Galois
Fields. And this is finite field
arithmetic where you've got to be able
to find a multiplicative and an additive
inverse. We've tried to prepare you for
this by doing ISBN book codes, which is a
very simple manifestation of those two
things. We thought in our early things [i.e. videos]
where a code word became a string of bits.
And some of those are information bits.
And interleaved with them, or parked at
the right-hand end very often, were
parity check bits. What we're now going
to try and do is instead of just having
one great long string of bits, linearly,
we're going to try and make it be almost
two-dimensional. Think of every one of
these positions in your code-word now
as not being a single bit but a column
of bits. Let's say it's an 8 bit column.
If you're doing something like Reed-Solomon
correction in a CD context, y'know,
how big is the bucket size of
these columns? I think it's something
like 40-odd bits but then even that
couldn't cope. They had, like, two layers
of Reed-Solomon encoding - one backing up
the other. So, if you like, the filling up
of these things, instead of linearly
going like that - and then at the very far
end you put a few parity check bits - what
we now do is we declare that every one
of these positions isn't a *bit* position
it's a *symbol* position but a symbol can
be multiple bits, OK? For the sake of
argument let's say it's an 8-bit symbol,
a byte. The way they get filled up is the
bit stream comes in and it fills up a
column of 8, and then it fills up a next
column 8 and a next column of 8. So it's
almost like we've got a 2-dimensional
array of bits - and symbols in that direction-
but every symbol is composed of 'n' bits, as
it goes along. What's the advantage of
doing that?  Well, you can see one
advantage, when you think about it,
straight away. Hamming codes, for example,
the old way, tended to presume you've got
the occasional error, now and then, wide
apart. What this is anticipating - if you
can fill up symbol positions - is you
might get 'burst errors'. Yeah, you might
get - here we go - bits coming off a CD,
trying to play your music.
It's encoded music. Now, if
they're filling up a bucket in a column,
in some sense, and then moving on to the
next one
there is just a chance that a localized
scratch will get all its 'bit-clobbering'
over and done with, within two symbols
shall we say. So,  we know that we can
devise codes that will can detect and
potentially correct a certain number of
errors but if we can make it so that
those errors are not [only] bit errors within
the symbol but just the symbol itself ...
something's wrong with it! Right?
You then might stand a chance if
you've got, again, parity-check *symbols* at
the far right-hand end -  not [just] parity-check
bits, if they've got enough information
in them, you might be able to say:
"Something went wrong. I got a burst error
there, as a scratch on that CD. Can I put
it right?" Yes, but it's not going to be
simple-minded parity checking; it's gonna
be serious hardcore stuff. Because those
check symbols at the end will normally
be arranged so that if the information
is correct and nothing's got damaged
there'll be zeros. If something gets
damaged,  the first thing you know about
it is that the parity-check symbols at
the end are nonzero. You're getting [perhaps]
3, 5, 12, 15. What does that mean?
well the answer is using
lots and lots of detective work - by the
way those symbols that you put on the
far right-hand end - revel in the name of
"syndrome", which i think is a wonderful
word. And my first thought was what on
earth are pure mathematicians, or
communications engineers, doing with
syndromes? They're medical aren' they?! Well, I
looked up in the dictionary and as far
as I can make out it all makes sense. If
you have a certain syndrome it means you
are exhibiting symptoms of an underlying problem
So the grouping of symptoms that's
caused by an underlying problem is often
called a syndrome. [There's] something like the
Guillain-Barre syndrome isn't there? I don't know what
it is but I'm no doubt you'll all put me
right on that. But you can see it makes
sense. The signal that something has gone
wrong is you get all of these
information bytes or even bigger columns,
multiple bytes, whatever. But right at the
end is now a "checksum from hell". You have
got a syndrome a set of remainders if
you like, that are not zeros. Given only
that information, how can you work
backwards and find out which of these
columns got hit and where in the column
it got hit? And the answer is: By using Galois
Field theory over finite fields and
doing lots and lots of long divisions
and additions. So, the bottom line is that
for this work and particularly if you're
using, as we are of course now, powers of
two, Galois said: "I can liberate you from
it having to be primes all the time,
I can do powers of primes. And for all of
you future computer scientists that I'm
not even aware of, you'll love this because
your beloved 2 comes into the real
world because where you say '4'  and I
say: Don't think of it as 2 x 2
Think of it as 2 ^ 2."
And so he said: "Yeah, I can do powers of
any prime, including two, but what he
didn't say is: Here are the rules
if you you light on 2 and say you want
to use my methods, here's rule number 1.
Everything must be done modulo 2
Not modulo your bigger number - like 256 -
that's different.
Modulo 2. So, for addition what do we know
about addition modulo 2, from Bletchley
Park Sean? What do the
mathematical logicians call 'addition
modulo 2' ?
>> Sean: This is exclusive OR
>> DFB: It's Exclusive OR! So, no sweat for computer
scientists. All our additions of these
numbers, represented in bytes or whatever,
are going to be done
with Exclusive OR. Worse still - as we
found out in the ISBN previous example -
you've got to be able to find
multiplicative inverses.  And that's going
to lead us into doing long divisions
modulo 2 in a Galois Finite Field. Now
that is a bit hair-raising but not too
terrifying. But if you're prepared in the
end to do all of that work then fine.
You can use your 'syndrome' and analyze
it to tell you where the errors went. That's
a lot of equation solving. For those of
you into these things it's like solving
lots of simultaneous equations saying [for example]:
"The only logical solution to this damage
is it absolutely must be column 3 and
column 13. That's where the damage has
come. Does that syndrome always work back
to getting your precisely one answer?
Yes - it's just magic the way that this
error correction works but it is complex
because the brute force way to do it is
to get a set of simultaneous equations
and - some of you will know this - get lots
of simultaneous equations to solve you use
'matrix inversion'. That is computationally
a very heavy undertaking. And so you're
looking all the time for simplifications
because, if you don't, you're sitting
there, like Sean and I were in the early
'80s, thinking: " ... this error correction [for CDs]
this is in real time! How is this thing
solving sets of matrix equations in real
time to make sure I can listen to this
CD without hearing the scratches? Where's
our supercomputer free with every CD - a
Cray XMP [in those days] - to solve your syndrome
equations?  Nope! what's the answer? You shake
head and think:
it's those hardware types! It's custom
hardware! Yes, custom hardware can fairly
easily attain supercomputer capabilities
so long as it's in a tightly defined
field. And it turns out, thank heavens,
that error correction in Reed-Solomon
schemes lends itself very nicely indeed
to things that computer engineers love
like "shift registers" [and pipelining]
and all sorts of
hardware 'specials'.